esata I'll start with you I understand
you had your first meeting with LinkedIn
in January but started more serious
discussions a few months ago why did you
decide this why now and how much did the
price drop have to do with it you know
to me Emeli this is a pretty exciting
day it's about really bringing together
the professional cloud which is at the
core of Microsoft and the professional
network the dream that we've always had
is how can we connect these two worlds
so that our mutual users who are the
professions of the world can get their
work done more seamlessly that's the
vision bringing the network with the
cloud I think it's very transformative
and I've been thinking about this for a
while and I've known Jeff and read for a
while and in starting in February we
started having some serious
conversations and once we started
talking about the possibilities of the
product and the coming together of that
mission that's when we said that havea
full combination can allow us to
accelerate what we both wanted to get
done to drive this next phase of growth
for us and that's what led us to hear
Jeff it was about the same time that you
and I had a very in-depth conversation
about how big you think the future
potential of LinkedIn is why would you
sell linkedin for a price less than it
was trading at six months ago yeah for
us that future just got bigger and it's
always been about the realization of our
long-term mission and vision and you
think about the global footprint that
Microsoft has a billion customers plus
and you think about the ability to
seamlessly integrate our network a
social fabric if you will throughout
Microsoft's ecosystem Outlook calendar
office window skype dynamics active
directory and the possibilities are
almost endless